first most important look we are now
five months into the coronavirus crisis
the most
central thing we can do in new york city
is keep ourselves
healthy keep the infection rate low in
this
city if we get that part right and new
yorkers have been heroes
fighting back against this disease we
keep this at a low level
everything else becomes possible
restarting our city restarting our
economy
it all depends on this so we're going to
talk about several things today but one
very very important piece of equation is
the offense here the
force that we've put together the fight
back against the disease the test and
trace core
we're going to talk about the latest on
that and how it's helping us keep that
infection level low
but i want to first talk about a couple
other really
important pieces that are happening
today that we need to talk about first
of all
question of evictions this is on the
minds of thousands and thousands of new
yorkers people
just trying to keep a roof over their
head look we have some good news today
and i want to thank governor cuomo he
signed executive order extending
some of the protections against eviction
for
tenants as a result of covid19 now we
need the court system to play their oil
so i'm calling on the state
court system please aggressively follow
up on this
executive order to protect tenants who
simply can't pay the rent because they
lost their income due to
the greatest crisis in generations
we need the court system to come in and
then we need the state in general
to address the bigger questions here
these eviction moratoriums
should not be something that just has to
be renewed all the time this needs to be
ongoing
for the extent of this crisis and then
for several months thereafter as people
hopefully consistently get back on their
feet
and have the money to pay the rent but
really what we need is part of the
stimulus
we need tenant assistance we need rental
assistance to help people get by
and we need the state to pass a law
giving tenants the ability
to pay the rent when they can if they
don't have any income what can they do
but for those who don't have income
giving them the opportunity to go on a
payment plan and pay back when they do
that's right for tenants and landlords
alike
we need state action on that front now
let's talk about
so much has happened last few days with
the storm that hit
this city yes uh first of all
the ongoing power outages this is an
unacceptable situation
uh con ed uh continues uh to
be unclear in their response and this is
something we've seen before and i really
wish kane would get the memo
that they have to be clear in their game
plan for new yorkers people are
depending on this power
the power has come back on consistently
i want to give
that credit but what i'm not happy about
is a lack of clarity and speed about the
next steps for the people of the five
boroughs so right now
just about 57 000 households
do not have power in new york city as a
result of the storm earlier in the week
from the latest we've heard from con ed
they are still sticking to the notion
they will add another
15 to 20 000 restorations today so
another
15 to 20 000 homes will get their power
back today based on the estimates we've
gotten from con ed i want to see that
number
greatly intensify telling people by the
end of sunday
is not a good answer we need to see that
speed up or certainly for the vast
majority of households and we'll keep
con ed's feet to the far
and we have urged them to move faster
but also offer whatever help they need
also you should know separate totally
separate from the storm earlier in the
week
there was an early morning outage
affecting over a hundred thousand
customers
that is a new outage it appears to have
been weather related
from weather activity last night but all
of those customers have been restored so
that was a very brief
outage now there's other damage of
course from the storm
this was the worst winds we had seen
since sandy and we saw the worst wind
damage since sandy
we are working with the state right now
and i certainly want to call on the
state to
authorize an emergency declaration given
what's happened in new york city give
what happened in long island this
certainly should be a state of emergency
and then that would help us to activate
fema support and funding now some people
reached out to me and said could fema
come in fema
is not in a position to come in with a
lot of resources that would have an
immediate impact in this kind of event
they often coordinate the resources of
other local
and state entities but what they can
help with for sure
is reimbursement for the cost so we need
a state declaration of emergency we need
fema funding to cover the very real
costs of this cleanup
now today we will have over 1 000
city state national guard
and private contractors working to clear
the tree damage so that's a substantial
number of personnel will be out there
from a wide range of city agencies
parks department department
environmental protection police
department fire departments
sanitation department a number of
agencies are getting involved combined
efforts
over a thousand personnel out conned has
apparently about 550 personnel out
our first concern of course is safety
there are still places where
there are real safety issues because of
downed power lines that has to be the
priority to get those lines secured
protect people's lives
we also need streets to be cleared at
this point there's been a number of
streets cleared but there's still 280
streets blocked in new york city
we'll have over 200 of those resolved by
the end of the day according to the
latest information from the parks
department the rest we expect to be
resolved
uh hopefully on saturday so a lot to do
there
we keep moving forward but now back to
the central issue that has been gripping
our lives
for the last five months how we fight
this virus
how we keep it from spreading how we
stop a resurgence
new yorkers have been heroes you've been
amazing the whole country is looking
with admiration in new york city for the
way we fought back
and test and trace is a crucial piece of
the equation
again this is this army of over 3 000
hard-working people out there every day
in communities on the phones finding
people helping people reaching people
literally stopping
thousands of new infections with their
work and it's an army that's growing
and part of the magic here is not just
to say
we need to get tested but also if you
are testing positive
to get you the help you need if you have
to safely separate from others so
amazing hit rate so far amazing
success 92 of all positive cases
have been reached thousands we now
estimate over 5
000 potential coronavirus cases
averted meaning 5 000 more people who
would have been infected were not
because
the folks who tested positive were
safely separated from the folks around
them
but we got a lot more to do we know big
big things coming on flu season is
coming
colder weather people more indoors
school coming back
a lot ahead so test and trace will be
more important than
ever and when testing trace calls you it
means
someone is calling not only trying to
stop the disease from spreading protect
you and your family but they're trying
to give you
help that if you need to safely separate
we will be with you every step of the
way
and the leading the charge the leader of
this piece
of the effort making sure that people
get
smart compassionate resourceful care for
whatever they need to get
through that period of isolation and
get healthy again the director of the
take care
initiative of test and trace dr amanda
johnson welcome doctor
thank you so much mr mayor as the mayor
mentioned
the take care arm of the test and trace
core is responsible for ensuring that
new yorkers have what they need to
safely separate
to date this program has looked like
helping new yorkers connect with a hotel
so that they have a physical space and
the amenities that they need
to prevent spreading the virus to their
loved ones their roommates their family
their friends
and for new yorkers who choose to
complete isolation of quarantine and
home
we'll deliver you the services that you
need to do so from the comfort of your
own home
we are really pleased to announce that
starting next week will actually be able
to deliver you the supplies that you
need to complete your safe separation
in the form of our take care package
so i'm going to walk you through the
contents of this package
some of which are going to be familiar
to you so having the weather the storm
over the past five months
you'll know that this is a medical grade
mask that you can use to protect
yourself from the other people who
reside in your homes
and we've also included hand sanitizer
for you
nothing takes the place of washing your
hands as frequently as possible but i
just want to take a moment to remark on
how
impressive it is that we're being able
to deliver hand sanitizer and masks
at a time where we would not have been
able to do so five months ago
we also have antibacterial wipes so that
you're able to clean the surfaces
so that you reduce the risk of
transmitting the virus to people who
share your household
we're also including two items to help
you with monitoring your health
during the time that you're isolating
and quarantining one is
a disposable thermometer this is really
important because your contact tracer is
going to call you and ask you about your
symptoms
and we specifically want to know if
you've registered any fever over the
past
day this will help us ensure that when
it comes time for you to exit your safe
separation you're able to do so
at the appropriate time we've also
included a medical device
in the kits that we're going to be
sending to cases so the people who have
been confirmed positive for covid
this is a pulse oximeter it gives you
two very useful pieces of information
one of which is your heart rate
the other is your oxygen level the level
of oxygen saturation in your blood
this information is really important
because a low oxygen saturation can be
an early warning sign that you need to
seek additional medical attention
you can have a low oxygen saturation
without even feeling breathless
so we're really pleased that we're able
to include this so that you have the
information you need to be able to
escalate care
when the time comes when and if the time
comes
we've also through the generosity
through of a couple of donors been able
to include a couple things to make
the duration of safe separation more
engaging and more productive
so we're really appreciative to kind for
the inclusion of a couple of kind bars
in the take care package
and we'd also like to thank microsoft
for providing information about how to
access online workshops and training
i know that was a lot of information but
we've also included
a booklet in the take care package so
that you can go over the resources that
are included
and also find information about how to
connect with other services that you
might need during the time of your safe
separation
this package is going to be translated
into 13 additional languages as well
we understand that being able to safely
separate comes down to more than just
tools it's about building relationships
with your contact tracer with your
resource navigator
so that they can help you get the
services that you need to safely
separate particularly if you choose to
do so at home
we're really proud of the work that the
15 community-based organizations
who form our core of over 200 resource
navigators
for the relationships they've built to
help people get the services they need
while they're safely separating at home
these tireless 200 plus resource
navigators have fielded over 8 000 calls
the people who have needed services
people who have reached out to us
during this really critical time they've
been able to connect
individuals to about 5 000
city services including prescription
medication delivery
as well as mental health services and
we've been able to enable
2000 individuals to receive food
delivery in their homes
i want to take this moment to extend my
appreciation to all the new yorkers out
there who have been participating in the
test and trace course so far
so if you've gone out and you've gotten
tested if you've picked up the phone
when your contact tracer has called you
if you've given information about your
contacts so we can help them know their
status and help them
safely separate i am indebted to you i'm
also very grateful for everybody who has
made the sacrifice to safely separate at
a home or hotel so that we can break the
chains of transmission
and stop the virus in its tracks thank
you so much and i'm going to turn it
back to
the mayor thank you so much dr johnson
excellent report and look everyone just
think about what dr johnson's been over
there
there's a very very comprehensive
extensive effort
to get people whatever support they need
we're not saying to people hey you're on
your own quite the opposite we're saying
we're going to be with you
every step of the way in fact if you
engage
with the test and trace effort you're
going to have a lot of support a lot of
compassion
a lot of creativity to get you the help
you need
and it just makes so much sense that
folks know they're going to be supported
they will do more to safely separate
from others
and that will stop the spread of disease
this effort is going to be even more
important
as we go into the fall so thank you
doctor for your great work and your
team's work
and look we are ever vigilant about this
disease so we also recognizing that
while we're serving
the folks in this city who need to
safely separate we're also very keenly
aware of folks traveling in or new
yorkers have been to one of the 35
states where there are problems coming
back
they need the test and trace core too
they need support in quarantining they
need information
and we're going to do that in a lot of
ways one of the things we're doing is
our checkpoints
we announced them earlier this week and
this is crucial this is both to help
people give them information let them
know how important it is if they're
in the situation according to state law
where they should quarantine
that this is how you do it and this is
the help you will receive
but it also will spread the word to all
new yorkers and all
visitors that this is really really
serious so the checkpoints began
with that clear message positive message
we're here to help but we've got to make
sure everyone takes this seriously
i want to thank everyone at the
sheriff's office they've been doing an
outstanding job the first stops
were about 200 vehicles just as a test
run
that number is going to grow greatly
this weekend but
unquestionably it will help to reach
thousands and thousands of people as
individuals but i think millions of
people get the message because these
checkpoints
that these quarantines must be honored
for the good of all
let me take us now to our daily
indicators and again
this makes the point how the discipline
the focus the hard work of new yorkers
everything we've been doing including
test and trace especially is keeping
these numbers
low so first daily number of people
admitted the hospitals for suspected
covert 19 threshold 200 patient today's
report
79 patients number two daily number of
health and hospitals icus
375 patients is the threshold 302 is the
number today
and most importantly people testing
positive
citywide for covid threshold 15 today's
report
one percent excellent number and
congratulations to all
and a few words now in spanish
torment
with that we'll turn to our colleagues
in the media please let me know the name
and outlet of each journalist
hi all we have with us here today dr
amanda johnson director of take care in
the test and trace corps
deputy mayor for operations anglin parks
commissioner
silver emergency management commissioner
criswell
sheriff vesito and senior advisor dr
varma
with that i'll start with dave evans
from abc7
dave were you there yes i'm here can you
hear there you go how you doing dave
i'm fine mayor hey i wanted to ask you
first of all a question about the
schools it sounds like we
may have some news from the governor
later i don't know how earth-shattering
it's going to be but i just wanted to
see your reaction
in that it sounds like it's going to be
a region by region thing
what the metric is for each region of
the number of people
with the infection rate so we could have
the schools in albany i guess
open and maybe the schools in new york
city not open but the
word is to proceed and act as if we are
going to have in
schools in classroom school this fall
but
if that metric kicks up and we have a
lot of people infected then i guess he
gets to
pull the plug in september is that is
that your understanding what's going to
be happening
dave you know appreciate the question
it's on everyone's minds we
i'm not going to comment until we get
the formal um formal decisions from the
state but there's been a lot
of close collaboration between the state
and the city on the notion of
tough thresholds in general during the
coronavirus crisis uh there's been
real unity on the notion that we were
going to be very careful and tough in
deciding
when to proceed through each phase you
know we went through phases one two
three four on time but with exceptions
in the city and state were unified on
those
exceptions on the schools you know i've
already said i want to hold new york
city schools to a
very tough standard and that is that
three percent standard over
a seven day period if our average goes
above
three percent infection in new york city
we would not open schools if it happened
during the school year we would close
them
so you know i believe we're all going to
be unified on that and vigilant
we need to open schools because we know
uh just
an extraordinary number we have 1.1
million school kids
and and three-quarters of our families
have said they want their kids back in
school they want that support they want
the kids do better
educationally than they can do remotely
they want everything that goes with
school the social development the mental
health services physical health services
food
our obligation to do our very best for
parents and families
but we're going to work with the state
to figure out what's safe that's what
counts most
go ahead so my second question is also
to do with schools i think today is the
day that
that parents have to decide if their
kids are going to stay home and learn
completely online
and not go into the classroom but my
question is i know you probably have
heard this before
it's kind of difficult to make that
decision isn't it if the parents don't
really know
what the classroom situation is going to
look like this fall like how many days
how safe it is all those things well i'd
say a couple things and i was a public
school parent for the entire education
of both my kids so i certainly can
relate to
the many many things parents are going
through now and made so much worse by
the pandemic it's really tough for
parents
but i also think new york city parents
are realist they understand we've gone
through a disruption like never before
and
and it's not going to look like a normal
year here's the deal
people have till the end of the day to
indicate if they
want to go with all remote from the
beginning we'll talk about that monday
we'll give an update once those numbers
are tabulated
uh of course at any point parents can
make that decision and they can go to
remote
pretty much instantly along the way if
they need to
but we also know again a survey of 400
000 parents is unheard of they get that
kind of response rate that
um most parents by far want the kids
back in school they understand it's
going to be blended learning
for the short term and dave i'll keep
saying this is not forever
you know five months six months seven
months i don't know exactly when but
there's going to be a day when there's a
vaccine and kids have it
and things go back to normal this is i
hope only part of our school year we're
talking about that gets affected by the
coronavirus
but if thinking through the perspective
of parents i'd say this
you know right now uh if you choose to
have your kids in school you know it's
gonna be some days a week
in the course of the next couple of
weeks you're going to get all the
details about your school's
schedule template and then your
individual child's
schedule you know that we're going to be
providing child care for as many people
as we can we're going to continue to try
and build that number up
and parents are going to use all the
resources of their command their family
friends fellow parents are all going to
work together it will not be easy
but i think most parents feel strongly
that even sometime in school is a lot
better for their kids than none
next we have david from the queen's
daily eagle
hi mr mayor two questions about
homelessness um yesterday you talked
about continuing to house
thousands of people experiencing
homelessness in commercial hotels
for the duration of the crisis to limit
covid in congregate shelters
commissioner banks said there have been
13 000 adults
moved into two bedroom uh two bedrooms
that's 6 500 rooms dhs says its average
is
237 a night with services that's more
than
a million and a half dollars a night 46
million dollars a month and it's a
stopgap solution so
officials in your administration have
talked about converting hotels for
permanent residential use either
relaxing sro law
are turning the hotels into permanent
supportive housing sites so will the
city do that
and what is the long-term housing plan
for people staying in hotels
david look you've done your research i
appreciate that um
yeah the goal here continues to be to
deal with the short
term which i'm just going to use a round
number let's say it's six months ish
while we're dealing with this crisis
until people are vaccinated then once we
get
through that we're going to of course
start to move out of those hotels and go
back into
the shelter system but we're going to
constantly try and reduce the number of
people in shelter with all the other
tools
we have we'll have a lot more to say on
that in the coming weeks but i think
we're going to have an opportunity here
to be creative and continue to get
people to other better
housing yes if we have control of a
facility and it's no longer needed
for shelter the goal is always to
convert it to permanent affordable
housing
but we also have to have enough shelter
available by law and morally
for folks who need it so different
pieces the answer but i think the simple
point is
job one is get folks out of the hotels
they've been in temporarily
back into the shelter system once it's
safe go ahead
so would you support changing the sro
law to
allow those hotels to be converted to
permanent use
well again the ones that there are there
are buildings we control
already uh and that's where we're
looking to or want to control
want to purchase where we're looking to
do permanent affordable housing
i think in terms of srl law i have to i
have to check that
i think there's some open questions
there that's something we'll come back
to on
but i will say to you and this has been
raised by a lot of folks
you know are there times when the city
can actually uh buy a building take over
a building
turn it into permanent affordable
housing that's what we've been trying to
do more and more that's actually showing
some success
let them be run by community-based
non-profit not by folks
you know trying to make a profit off and
off often off the uh
the misery of others so
that's our main thrust but i will come
back to you on the sro law
we have marla from wcbs 880.
good morning mr mayor i have two
questions one concerning education the
city comptroller
was talking about holding classes
outside
how feasible would this be to do in new
york city
marla it is something we want to take
advantage of for sure the chancellor's
been very clear about that but it's not
a reliable solution you got a couple of
problems you got
rain and storms you got cold weather
i think it's fair to say in september
october you might have some
opportunities to do some things outside
i think it's fair to say in may june but
a lot of the year it's just too cold
some folks have said roofs a lot of the
roofs just wouldn't work the way they're
configured for kids to go up there
wouldn't be safe
this about safety and health first um
and just a reality that you got to have
a certain amount of reliability and
consistency when you're running a school
but that said
schools are welcome to be flexible that
if there's good weather and they've got
the right
opportunity the way their schools set up
and they can get kids outside we're
going to work with schools in each and
every situation and take advantage of as
many days as we can
go ahead marla uh mr mayor there was
quite a bit of blowback on social media
yesterday about your advice not to buy a
car
with your critics saying you aren't
doing anything to discourage people from
driving and it does appear
anecdotally that more are driving as
they try to stay off mass
transit and uh one of the questions was
you get driven around in chauffeured car
how are you going to get to the gym in
brooklyn once it reopens
you know marla that's just uh not
pertinent to what we're dealing with
right now right now we are dealing with
a crisis where the job one is to give
people confidence
again in mass transit and i want to say
the city and state work together
to show that the mta could be a lot
cleaner subways buses people have been
coming back
city bike has been a big part of the
solution people are coming back to
staten island ferry
new york city ferry this is the way
forward i've been clear for years
i'm not going to have a car in the
future
i don't think cars make sense for the
future in new york city people may use
them
in the short term because of the crisis
fine but this is a crisis again
that could be over in a half year give
or take
then we continue to deepen our
commitment to mass transit and other
options because that's the future of the
city
next we have debra lee from manhattan
times and bronx free press
hey good morning can you hear me yeah
deborah lee how are you
i'm well thanks good morning to all mr
mayor i wanted to ask you about concerns
raised by staff and teachers and
administrators
i'm specifically at ms324 in washington
heights which services
about 1400 students and the concerns
that they raise is they are emblematic
of many of the campuses across the city
they formed a school safety committee
and they're expressing concern that
previous 2018 building facilities report
from the doe and the city and
independent engineer evaluation
since point to the campuses ventilation
system is inadequate
and while individual classrooms have ac
that the filtration systems just don't
exist and again all together
the system is defective and that's from
an independent analysis made
by the city and that repairs have not
been issued have not been done since
then
and as they enter into now the final
weeks of preparation
their concern is that they are in fact
not ready
what is the city doing to address these
concerns specifically despite the fact
that their reservations on the part of
parents
the buildings themselves what is the doe
and the city doing to help prepare
uh the facilities to be able to receive
students
just say that say the number of the
school again deborah lee
ms 324 in washington heights it services
about 1400 students
thank you i'm going to follow up with
the chancellor today
on that specifically look um the bottom
line here is we have been working
on all fronts to make schools safe
uh there are a variety of ways to do
that do not forget for a moment
every classroom will be socially
distanced every part of the school will
be socially distanced
you're talking about a classroom will
have
10 kids 12 kids in a very small number
with distance
everyone will have a face covering
students and adults alike
cleaning incessantly hand sanitizer
hand washing stations incessantly
there's a lot of pieces to how you fight
back the disease
so we absolutely want to make sure that
the circulation systems are in good
shape if there's a specific problem in a
school we're going to deal with that
and we'll be open about that there's
going to be a lot of different pieces
that come together so thank you for
raising this and we'll look into it
immediately but rest assured that
there's there's a lot of pieces that
create safety for our kids go ahead
and and as a follow-up to that express
uh
has been an explicit has been the
concern ongoing for parents and families
about
not having adequate technology resources
even as they face a choice between being
online
or facing a hybrid model can you speak
to what
the city and the doe have done in the
last few months and for that matter what
parents can do in these last few weeks
of preparation to be able to access
resources because many of the parents
that we're speaking to still continue
to be stymied by access to to
online learning resources so
let me say the most important point is
getting
devices and getting service in the hands
of every child who needs it there was a
herculean effort by the doe i give them
a lot of credit 300
000 devices uh distributed in very short
order while setting up remote learning
for the first time
at a vast level look that's a everyone
who has a complaint has a right to
complain everything we have to do better
we have to do better but let's stop and
appreciate our educators
and the doe and all the companies got
involved they were asked to create
remote learning for 1.1 million kids in
a matter of weeks from scratch it'd
never been
anticipated to have to do it on this
level this quickly in the history of new
york city but they did it
imperfect yes but they did it 300 000
uh devices distributed in a matter of
weeks
one of the most actually direct ways of
addressing the digital divide we've also
seen in new york city's history but any
kid who doesn't have a device will get
one for free any device that's not
working will be replaced anyone doesn't
have service will get service
uh the same methodology for letting the
don
doe know if you need it is there and
anyone who's not sure can simply call
3-1-1
but that's going to be an ongoing effort
i've heard a few people say oh whatever
device breaks we'll replace it
it's as simple as that next we have emma
from the new york times
hi mayor um i know i've been harping on
this issue but um i wanted to talk with
you about testing again
um you had asked me to go to a city site
if we needed a testing again and we did
we've been waiting for the results for
two weeks so it seems very critical to
the school's plan
to have testing that uh with short
turnaround times
what do you say to parents who you know
kid has
a runny nose or a fever and they want to
get tested well first of all i
appreciate the question emma it's so
important
i'm very sorry what you've been through
and i honestly don't understand where
the breakdown is which
site could you do you mind saying which
site you went to
yeah we went to highbridge pool which is
a health and hospitals run site
but they send their testing to quest
diagnostics
lab which apparently is the one with the
slowdown right
that's where the problem is so i spoke
to the ceo
of quest yesterday we had a very
productive conversation
uh you and others went through something
absolutely unacceptable
it was directly related to the massive
overload that occurred
all around the country the combination
of the huge uptick in the disease in
other parts of the country
and actually also ironically a lot of
businesses coming back and putting very
intense testing programs into place so
what happened was quest just got
overloaded all over the country and and
they
are were spread thin they have resolved
a lot of that
uh what we agreed on is over the next
week or two uh the quest turnaround for
new york city will get to
four days or less on that
you know we obviously want one day two
day that's always our goal but four days
or less we can work with
but the ceo is quite clear that the the
worst is behind them they've added a lot
of capacity and we should not see that
problem again but again i'm sorry to you
and anyone who went through that
go ahead now thanks bud i appreciate it
um but in terms of if if it is four days
um
you're just expecting if if a child
shows symptoms any symptom related to
covid
they would keep their home their child
home for those four days um
until they can confirm that they don't
have the virus correct
yeah any any time you see symptoms we
want and in fact we insist that families
i'm saying this as a parent
i would abide by this in a heartbeat i
expect every parent to abide by if your
child's sick if your child's showing
those symptoms
keep your child home keep your child
home until they are well
and also let's get that test and if it
comes back negative great if it comes
back positive
you gotta go through the whole course of
uh that pause until you come back
next we have henry from bloomberg
hello mr mayor how are you doing today
i'm doing okay henry how about you
i'm doing pretty well i want to get back
i mean have you heard from the governor
on what his decision is going to be or
is he withholding this
as a big surprise i haven't heard from
as
i've said henry first of all he said
he'd give an announcement at some point
today the day is young
there's been a lot of communication our
teams are talking constantly
really constantly on a whole host of
things and i do understand the governor
has to think about the differences
between the regions and the state that's
a real
real obligation that i fully understand
but
i'm sure we'll hear more in the course
of the day and
we welcome tough standards because
that's what we believe in here i've
said proactively we want to hold
ourselves to that three percent standard
that's much lower than any other
standard i've heard around the country
but we believe new york city is up to
that because of how well we've done over
the last two months
keeping the infection level down go
ahead henry
okay but the governor has also said that
the
two major considerations are the
parental
and union buy-in and
from reporting that i've done and others
have done
the unions are still extremely skeptical
and fearful really about
the health consequences of subjecting
teachers
to the classroom and parents are
also skeptical number one that the
remote learning experience
has really been improved to the point
where
it's going to engage students and on the
other hand
they've got concerns about
the health consequences of sending their
kids to school so
in light of all that uh
does it cause you any concern that
the governor will decide not to
go along with your plan henry i'm not
going to speculate i appreciate the
question it's an honest question i'm
just not going to speculate it doesn't
get us anywhere
the governor will come to his final
decision we will work with it now the
parent buy-in this is a known fact i
again respect everyone but i ask
everyone when we when we bring you an
exceptional piece of information
please give it its due 400 000 people
responding to a survey and 75 percent
say they want their kid back in school
i've talked to a huge number of parents
myself everywhere i go
i i make sure to talk to parents and
i've actually talked to a lot of
educators too
i get overwhelmingly that people want to
come back
no one underestimates the challenges but
they're new yorkers they're tough
they're strong they're resilient
they see all these other good people out
there fighting
for their fellow new yorkers our
healthcare heroes our first responders
teachers are incredibly devoted people
i tell you a lot of educators have said
to me
i know i can't do as much for the kids
remotely i want to be there in person
with them because i can't help them
if i'm so far away from them and i
really honor that about educators
so i think what we have is a huge level
of parent buy-in based on what we've
seen so far but we're going to have
facts for you on monday because parents
will get to make that decision by the
end of the day for the first
round and we'll that will tell us a lot
and then we've been working with the
unions
daily to address a whole host of issues
and there's still a long time on the
clock here to keep addressing those
issues so
i feel strongly we can bring the pieces
together
uh because it's the right thing to do
it's the right thing to do for our kids
it's the right thing to do for our city
and we're going to keep working to make
sure it's safe
last two for today next we have gersh
from streetsblog
hello mr mayor thank you for taking the
call it's about to ask one of the
easiest most basic questions i've ever
asked you
on this call on friday may 29th police
commissioner shea
was asked what percentage of police
officers live in the suburbs
he said he didn't know the number of
hand which is fine and he asked
reporters to call the nypd press office
for that number
mr mayor my outlet and has asked for
that simple number six times i know
other reporters have
and we have not gotten that number does
it bother you that the nypd press office
won't answer this basic question
among others it does i'm glad you're
asking it no it makes no sense
um we know two crucial things about
today's nypd
it is a majority people of color and it
is more and more
new york city residents my understanding
is we're getting close to a break-even
point
in terms of folks who live in the city
versus suburbs but i want to get the
exact numbers we will get you that
number today even if it's
a close estimate we'll get you that
number today but no you should not have
had to ask that so many times that's
crazy
okay and i do have a follow-up related
to your oversight of the nypd so mr
mayor last year
you responded to reports of reckless
driving by nypd officers
by pledging to revoke parking permits
for cops who get too many camera issued
speeding tickets
now the nypd just last month finally
turned your promise
into policy by updating the patrol guide
now it turns out according to that
patrol guide that a cop has to get
15 camera issued speeding tickets in one
year before losing his
parking permit so i ask you is 15
speeding tickets in 12 months
the threshold you wanted when you
revealed your new policy last year
not if they are in civilian
use of their car now i what i need to
get clear
and we will get you this answer is if pd
was putting that number in because they
know a certain
percentage of the time it's in the line
of duty or people
are rushing to a job that's one thing
but if that's about civilian use no that
doesn't make sense so let me get more on
that we'll come back
last one for today we have reuven from
hamodia
good morning mr mayor i would like to
ask you about your
comments yesterday opposing the
governor's interest in
accommodating the wealthy new yorkers
who wanted to leave
you frequently mentioned how how bad the
city's
financial straits are right now isn't
losing these wealthy people
and wealthy taxpayers going to hurt the
budget even more
it's a very important question and i
appreciate what i'm trying to say first
of all is let's focus on working people
let's focus on the millions upon
millions of people who do their jobs
every day or are fighting to get their
jobs back
who need help who are the backbone of
the city the heart and soul of new york
city they're not going anywhere they're
not fleeing this is new york
and these are the new yorkers i'm here
to fight for
the wealthy have become more uh
global in many ways not because of this
crisis long before
much less rooted they will come they
will go
some are true new yorkers we got a lot
of homegrown millionaires here that's
great i know a lot of them
really care about new york city and do a
lot for new york city god bless them the
folks who want to be a part of this
community god bless them and if they've
done well in life
congratulations now let's help out other
people
but i am not going to beg anybody to
live in the greatest city in the world
there are plenty of people who want to
live in new york city there are plenty
of people who come here no matter what
this crisis will be over soon and here's
what we found we actually analyzed this
in recent years some millionaires and
billionaires have left
some millionaires and billionaires have
come in and started to
grow roots here in new york city and
here's the most important fact
new york city has bred more millionaires
every year in recent years than ever
before because up until february our
economy was
booming and people from all over the
world wanted to come here
sensing opportunity and they will again
so
i am convinced uh that by focusing on
you know restoring this city and doing
what's right for working people in this
city
it will be a better and better and
fairer place and i actually think
that's where creative people want to be
entrepreneurial people want to be and
that's our path back
go ahead and in regard to your desire
to raise taxes even further on the
wealthy the wealthiest one percent of
new yorkers
already pay more than 40 percent of the
total personal income taxes paid in the
state
how much is this is enough
look i'll i'll simply go back to if you
want to talk about fair taxation in
america
and when america worked most fairly and
equitably
unquestionably it's the period after
world war ii
up through the 1960s we saw a huge
amount of economic growth
we saw much less income inequality
we saw everyday people getting a piece
of the pie and working their way to
middle class
we saw a huge amount of government
investment in
health care infrastructure science
research
education and the highest
tax rates that wealthy people ever
experienced
were under the administration of that
well-known left-wing
socialist general dwight eisenhower
so i honestly believe that
we had the model right at one point and
we lost our way and we need to go back
to
a model closer to that time where the
wealthy truly pay their fair share
and our country can invest in its people
everybody look let me close today with
this we talked about a lot of different
topics
the most important topic always is
fighting back this disease
the people have done this in new york
city you're going to hear
conversation all the time about what the
government did the city the state the
federal government that matters but much
more important is what the people do
the buy-in of the people the strength of
the people the belief of the people
uh that we could fight back new yorkers
have shown it we got to be there every
step away to support the people this is
why test and trace is so important
giving people the help they need giving
them the support
if you need to safely separate knowing
you're not alone you're going to get all
the help you need
and the people also can remind each
other including any of our friends who
are traveling or
family members coming here that this
quarantine for folks who've been out of
state
really matters so i have faith in the
people
no one wants to see this city go back to
where we were in the beginning of this
horrible crisis
but in fact new yorkers have proven it
doesn't have to be that way because of
your hard work let's keep doing it
thanks everybody